[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
I hope everybody is
having a great week.
I'm having an extra great
week because I'm calling
in from Puerto Rico today.
I'm Rachael Dempsey, and I lead
our pro community at Posit.
I always want to put
this plug out there
that we have the Posit
Conference coming up
in September.
And we just extended the
call for talks to April 7th.
So I just want to
make sure everybody
knew that that call
for talks got extended.
But back to regular
scheduled programming.
The Data Science Hangout
is our open space
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing, and getting
to hear about what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
And it happens every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So if you're watching
this recording on YouTube
later in the future, the
link to add these sessions
to your calendar will
be in the details below.
But every week we get to feature
a different data science leader
as my co-host to help lead
our discussion and answer
questions from you all.
And so, together, we're all
dedicated to making this
a welcoming environment
for everybody that joins.
So we love to hear
from everyone,
no matter your level of
experience, or industry,
or area of work.
It is totally OK to
just listen in as well.
But there's also three
ways you can jump in
to either ask
questions or provide
your own perspective too.
So you can raise
your hand on Zoom,
and I'll be on the lookout here.
You can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to put a
little star next to it
if it's maybe loud where you
are and you want me to read it.
And then, third, we
also have a Slido link
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
But thank you so much,
Oscar, for joining us today
as our co-host.
Oscar Baruffa is joining
us as our featured leader.
And, Oscar, I would love
to have you maybe jump in,
and introduce yourself,
and share a little bit
about your role, and, I
guess, also something you
like to do outside of work too.
Oh, yeah.
Thanks.
Yeah, so it's really
nice to meet everyone.
I'm a senior analytics manager
at a company called idea IDH.
IDH is a international
development organization
that works on improving the
sustainability of global supply
chains, mostly in the
agricultural and manufacturing
sectors.
And the team, now, these
development organizations
are usually organized
into specific programs
that you work on.
And the program that I'm
working on specifically
works with businesses that
work with smallholder farmers
across the world.
So you can think maybe there's
a company that's getting--
maybe a local company
in Africa that's
sourcing potatoes
for the local market.
Maybe there's international
coffee companies
sourcing coffee from all
over the world, basically.
And we work with those companies
to improve the business models,
that interaction, say, between
these companies that source
produce and the farmers
that produce it.
Because often, many
of these farmers
are living quite far
below the poverty line.
They need a lot of
services delivered to them
and various things like that.
So we work a lot with that.
And my team, very
specifically, analyzes data
from lots of different
business models.
And we're trying to understand
which characteristics
of these models improve
outcomes for their profitability
and sustainability, like
economic sustainability,
of the company
working with them,
and the livelihoods
of the farmers
that are part of that
interaction as well.
That's a lot what we do.
It's quite a small team as well.
And that's it.
So we're basically,
there's myself
as the analytics manager.
Then there's two data
analysts and a data engineer,
and I mean a bunch
of other people
in the team, lots of data
people, that's the most direct.
Outside of work, I think my time
is split quite evenly between--
I still do more data stuff.
I blog quite a lot about
data-related, career-related
topics, and whenever I
get the time to do so.
I also-- one of
my pride and joys
is I created and I maintain
this repository of R programming
books.
It's called the Big Book
of R. And yeah, so just
recommend anyone go
have a look at it.
It's got over 350 titles of
just about any topic focused
on R programming.
And the remainder
of my time, I've
got some young children who
are just at the age now,
which is fantastic, that they
can start playing Mario Kart.
The one's getting
into Raspberry Pi.
So I spent most
of my last weekend
trying to get a VJ screen
to work with a Raspberry Pi.
And I was not successful.
And so, this weekend,
I think, we're
going to try to find
an old HDMI screen.
But yeah, so that's all
my free time, basically.
That's awesome.
Thank you, Oscar.
And I was going to say, you are
like a celebrity to us here.
I feel like we've often
shared the Big Book of R
in the chat and a
bunch of resources.
So it's so nice to
have you here with us.
Thanks.
Yeah, that's great.
And Oscar, I know we
chatted a little bit
about some discussion
points that we wanted
to bring up in the
beginning as we
wait for questions to come in.
But one thing I wanted
to ask you about
is you mentioned theory of
constraints in visible work
along with the negative
feedback loop in data work.
And I was curious to
have you expand on that
and share a little bit more
about what that means to you.
Yeah, so I've always managed--
a bit of the background here
is, I've always found my--
I've always thought of
myself, as a competent project
manager of projects,
whereas it doesn't matter--
I mean, I wouldn't say I'm the
best ever, but I'm pretty OK,
I'd say.
I get things delivered
on time, and usually
within budget, and sometimes
very difficult conditions.
And so, it really interests me
a lot about the management of
projects.
And I even wrote
a very short book
that's free to
newsletter subscribers,
but it can be free to
anyone here as well,
about project
management fundamentals,
specifically for data analysts.
So I think about this
type of thing a lot.
And I'm aware of-- you get
agile practices and a few others
for managing projects.
But I only very
recently picked up
this book, The
Phoenix Project, which
I'm sure probably many
people here have read
or some have heard.
I would highly
recommend reading it.
It's really-- it's
interesting from a few ways.
One in its delivery of teaching
you theoretical material
through the use of a novel.
I'd never experienced
something like that before.
So that was just
interesting on its own.
But the second was that it
introduced such teaching
in this concept, the
theory of constraints,
and how it relates to management
of delivery of projects.
That book itself is based on
another book called The Goal.
And The Goal was
written in the '80s by--
I can't remember his
name exactly, but it's--
his surname is
Goldratt, I think.
And this-- so he gets talking
about the theory of constraints
and what its implication
is for how you manage work,
and how you assign
resources, and how you, yeah,
prioritize things, basically.
And why it's also interesting
is because out of it,
out of all this, this idea
of visible work also emerges.
So these things are all
quite tightly interwoven.
And I've developed this--
I had a bit of an epiphany while
reading The Goal, which is--
and I think I need to read
both again to really dig in--
but I had a bit of
an epiphany that I'm
hoping others recognize, or
they've seen the solution to,
or people just like, oh,
yeah, that is a thing,
or am I just being
a bit crazy here?
So if you are not familiar
with the theory of constraints,
the very, very
basics of it is that
in any system of
production, and that
includes knowledge work, where
your work is being handed off
between people, or in a
manufacturing setting,
your car parts need to
go through some machine
at some point.
Somewhere in this line of
the series of work events,
one or more of the
items, or one or more
of the work sensors, as they
call it, is your bottleneck.
Your bottleneck is
your constraints.
And you need to--
you'll get optimum performance
out of the whole system
if you design around
the constraints.
Most people design
around the full capacity
of maximizing every single
work census capacity.
And that causes huge
all sorts of issues.
I'm not going to
recount the whole book.
But the idea is that you
basically scale everything done
and keep the constraints fully,
let's say, fully capacitated.
And when I was reading
it, I thought, yeah,
it makes a lot of sense.
And a lot of what
they were saying I
recognize in my own
stuff I've learned
in a reverse-engineered
kind of way.
Like, yeah, you don't
want to maximize
everyone's capacity, and
queues, and workloads, and this.
So it was really quite
mind-blowing, lots
of what I was reading.
But there's one thing that I--
now, here's my
epiphany-- that the idea
is that your constraint needs
to be able to keep pulling work
as it's available.
And that's the whole idea
of having visible work.
You keep pulling work
as it's available.
And that's work going
through the constraints
goes to other work sensors.
If there's any delay
at the constraint
or any lowering of capacity
at the constraints,
the problem is that you keep
building-- each of those delays
becomes cumulative.
And that's why small
delays, especially
if your constraint's
somewhere near the front,
or I don't remember
the exact positioning,
but you get very
large delays later on.
And that's why
you'll see, I mean,
you can see it when
people are working,
small issues up front
becomes someone else's
massive nightmare
down the chain.
And they can just never
catch up with work
that was overwhelming.
Because they're dealing with
all this upstream cumulative
delays.
And the cumulative delays are
super important to be aware of.
But now, the solution,
I think, doesn't quite
work for much of
data work, that just
in maximizing the capacity
of your bottleneck.
And I think, the reason
is, now, I'm not talking--
so most of my data work has
been around, you could say,
data analytical work,
not productionizing
machine learning systems.
I think productionizing that
is more akin to the DevOps
environment, like in IT,
someone designing and developing
something and then handing
over to someone else to deploy.
That's more like how
everything else usually works.
But in a lot of data work
that's very iterative,
there's a huge problem
in that, most likely,
your bottleneck becomes a
victim of its own delays.
Because work often is not done.
It's not just handed over.
By necessity, you've got to hand
over an analysis to someone.
But that's not the end of it.
We all know it comes back again.
And a lot of the techniques that
otherwise you might build in
to reduce that rework--
in a software setting, the
whole theory of contracts
talks about having
feedback of information.
But not of the work itself.
The work itself isn't
supposed to come back.
We deal with the work coming
back again because you can't--
a lot of the work, you can't--
especially if it's exploratory,
any kind of exploratory
data analysis,
you're doing a research, and
you're not sure what the answer
is going to be like.
There's no way you
can specify upfront
what the outputs should be.
And no matter what
you did at the first--
how good your
specification was, you
will still get a reaction
from whoever is consuming it
that they want more
information, or a feedback
that once your bottleneck
has freed themselves,
usually it's your analysts
and that of the work,
it comes back.
That's just the nature.
The reason it comes
back is because you
were successful in the
first place, I think.
So now, the only
further bits I've
gotten of how you might
be able to deal with this
is when you need to tweak
the whole visible work
and all of that system
a little bit is not
to maximize your constraints.
Your constraints also
need slack to take up
the rework that's coming back.
And the reworking of
work that comes back,
you need to probably have some
variable system that you'll--
I mean, it's going to
be very hard to get this
to an exact science.
But it will be a function
of how much have you already
pushed out?
So the more that you pushed
out, the more variability
you need to leave
in your capacity
until you show that this is
not going to come back again.
You'll need some way to
know that this work ticket
item is done.
The project's done.
The investment's
been made, whatever,
and you're not going to
get more coming back.
So that was quite
a big aha moment
that I had a little while ago.
Because I was thinking, how
could we implement this?
And I just saw it just wouldn't
work, it's like, let's say,
true form.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
It's interesting you just
said that exact part there.
Because I was just reading
that part in the Making
Work Visible book.
It's taking me a little
bit to get through it.
But we just talked
about that part.
OSCAR BARUFFA: Yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I
see, Marlene, you
had a follow-up
question to what Oscar
is talking about right now.
Do you want to jump in?
Hi, Oscar.
Thanks for the
talk this morning--
well, it's morning where I'm at.
I'm just curious.
You're talking
about decisions that
get compounded down
the line, especially
in production systems.
I'm just wondering,
in your experience,
how much of those constraints
have happened from managers,
supervisors, c-suite, anybody
above you on the totem pole
versus maybe lateral
to you or below.
Roughly what percentage do
you think you've seen that?
Good question.
I don't know.
It would be hard.
I think it's maybe more those
who are dependent on the output
to move forward at all are
the ones who, I would say,
maybe more excluding
the c-suite,
or the executive decision-maker.
Because my expense
is, in a way, they
don't seem to get impacted
at all other than still
just moving forward
with actual information.
So there's usually maybe--
a lot of the work we do
is often in, as well,
in publishing some
kind of documents
or a report of some kind.
It's that person, that
last one, maybe just
before it gets to the
c-suite, like let's say
in the theory of
constraints language,
and that that's where
it leaves the workshop,
at that technical
person's point of view.
So I'd say it's, for me, it's I
would maybe classify it as 100%
laterally.
Above that from the decision--
they need to go forward anyway.
And that's also where it starts
becoming important to manage
these things better.
Because you don't want
to become irrelevant
work center service provider
to the organization.
If your stuff is just
never ready or good enough
because of your
delays or whatever,
people are going to go ahead.
They were going ahead before
your data team was around,
and they're going to keep
going ahead without you.
Maybe not for the better of
the organization, but yeah,
I'd say it's 100% laterally.
That's for me, at least,
where my focus has been.
Yeah, great.
Thank you.
OSCAR BARUFFA: Yeah.
I see that there was a
question in Slido that was,
what compelled you to
start the Big Book of R?
Yeah, that's a good one.
So I love talking about the Big
Book of R. So that was about,
yes, it was August 2020
that I launched it.
And a little bit
before that, I've
just been bookmarking
lots and lots of books,
especially then, well, I
mean, until just recently,
I was on Twitter a lot.
And then I was all
the time on Twitter.
And people were sharing
their books and that.
And I just started
bookmarking them.
And I remember at
once seeing my set,
my bookmarks folder had
80 of these R books.
And I'd not seen a
collection of such.
And I'd just put out
a call basically.
I said, hey, anyone
else is collecting?
How many do you have?
I was just trying to compare.
Am I-- and most people
coming back with 5, 10, 25.
I thought, wow,
actually, I've somehow
stumbled upon this
massive repository.
And then also, it was
one of those things
I thought, oh, maybe I could
just quickly put this together.
Because I'd also
just actually written
a book called Twitter
For R Programmers,
which was a collaborative
effort with Veerle van Son.
And so, I just had this-- it was
my first time using R Markdown,
and I quite liked
the thought of being
able to make a
book really easily.
So then these things
just came together.
I saw, oh, I've got this massive
thing, this great repository,
and this great collection.
So that was the start of
it, it's at around 80 books.
And, yeah, it's been
really fun project.
Thank you for that
contribution to the community
too.
I know there's so many people
who have used that resource.
There is actually a
way you can help me,
actually, everyone, if you want.
There's a-- I'm applying
for a R Consortium grant
to basically upgrade
the Big Book of R.
And so, I'm collecting--
basically, I don't know,
it's a 2-minute survey where
you can just add your name
and if you think this
is a good idea or not.
It's part of the submission.
So I think I've got
about 110 responses.
So if I can get 150,
then it can be really,
wow, everyone really thinks
this is a great resource.
So I'll share it in
the chat just now.
I just put it in the chat too.
But make sure--
OSCAR BARUFFA: Ah, yeah, you
did. you are ahead of me.
Thanks, Rachael.
Yeah, fantastic.
That would be great to get a
few more statements of support.
Thanks.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Absolutely.
Yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Ben, I see
you had asked a question
in the chat a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah, Oscar,
first of all, thanks
for all the contributions
to open source,
especially in the R environment.
But what benefits have you
seen from those contributions
to your career overall?
Wow, a good question.
Yeah, I'd say quite a few.
One is just that it's--
yeah.
How do I put this?
There's a certain-- this
isn't the right word,
but certain level of
confidence that you
get that it's like, wow, I'm
doing something that gets
validated quite quickly.
A lot of our work,
a lot of my work
anyway, there's so much stuff
that I really like doing,
and it's really good.
But who's going to know that
it's good or bad other than me?
It's really difficult know.
My managers are non-technical.
If I make something that's
a really terrible back-end
and everything's
all jangly together,
or it's a super, super great
system, it's hard for them
to do that.
So this is one way
that's at least it's
great to get that kind
of validation externally,
that, yeah, I apply the
same kind of, let's say,
level of effort and
enjoyment in both elements.
So at least this is one--
a sample of my work that
gets a lot of thumbs up.
So that's really great.
It's also been quite
useful in getting
a good overview
of the R ecosystem
and what people
are using it for.
And for example,
I noticed if you
want to do stats or
something, there's
tons of books, lots of them.
If you want to do geographic
information stuff,
there's quite a
few books as well.
I work a lot with Excel
in my daily work as well,
lots, and lots, and lots.
And there's Excel packages.
No books about
working with Excel.
And so, when I was doing
quite a big project--
and we do interact
quite a lot with it.
But I always knew
that at some point
we would be limited
with what some of what R
could do with Excel.
And we did hit those limits.
But I was not surprised
by them at all.
That's a small thing.
But had I not already had this
big overview of everything that
goes on in R, I may have walked
a bit more blindly into that.
And also, meeting people
has been really fantastic.
So often people tag
me on stuff and then
I start recognizing authors.
Or I've been asked to review
some book proposals as well.
So you'll get, especially
from CRC Press,
they do quite a lot of R books.
Publications, I've been asked
to look at some of those.
It's quite nice to see what
some people are working on way
before it's released.
Yeah, so it's been
really fun all around.
And I must say, that
it wasn't something
that would happen at the start.
I just thought, that
would be really cool.
But it's been great fun.
Awesome.
I see there was an anonymous
question that I just
want to make sure I covered.
Somebody asked if there
was a grant program
to assist students who wish
to attend Posit Conference?
And I just wanted
to let everybody
know that Hannah
shared in the chat
that we do have an Opportunity
Scholars Program as well.
And she put the link in there.
But, Jonathan, I see you
have your hand raised.
Do you want to jump in next?
Yeah, absolutely.
And, Oscar, thank you very
much for co-hosting today.
Rachael, thanks for putting
this together, as always.
So one thing I felt that I
could add to the conversation.
I work in risk underwriting
for the subprime.
I've been doing it for
about six years now.
And it's a very flat
organization, FlexShopper.
And one thing I've
learned within the theory
of constraints,
applying it here,
is that priorities tend
to shift very rapidly.
And it really causes a
lot of context-switching
amongst the team.
And one way that I've introduced
to help to control that is--
even though it's not ideal, and
hopefully maybe somebody else
might be able to chime
in on this later--
is just having them create
ticket stubs for everything
they get.
So in that effect, if
they get a-- if they
get a new priority saying,
hey, get on this now, just
put a ticket stub
in, have it there.
So that way, when we're done,
we can go back and figure out,
all right, well, what
are we doing over here?
Oh, we were doing this,
that, and the other thing.
Here we go.
And it doesn't eliminate
the context-switching,
but it definitely
helps to reduce it
to the effect of
you can almost pick
up right where you left off.
And it's helped to bring up
the efficiency by around,
I would say, 20% in terms
of turning tasks around.
Yeah, no, great.
Yeah, and the
context-switching is all--
I've felt it myself.
And I've seen it
with others as well.
If you can reduce
context-switching outputs,
it's massively--
it's much better.
But also, people's
job satisfaction
is way higher, and
including my own.
But it's getting harder and
harder to not context-switch.
But I have noticed, even
for myself, that switching,
even if it doesn't
get your work up--
let me put it this way.
Even if it didn't
improve productivity,
it improves work satisfaction.
It's a huge retention gain.
But, yeah, that's great, and
especially on the tickets.
That's a good one.
Thanks, Jonathan.
Yeah, thank you.
Ahnas, I see you have
your hand raised too.
You want to jump in?
Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you, Rachael.
So I'm going to piggyback off
Jonathan's question, Oscar.
So I like how you describe
the difference between how
the theory of constraints
affects it broadly,
and then how it affects us
specifically in data science.
So what are other
methods that you've
tried to help reduce that piece
where we're repeating analysis.
And it kind of left me
on a cliffhanger there.
I'm like, what are some
things that you've experienced
and things that you'd recommend?
And then, I have a second
question, if I can.
Going back to the Big
Book Of R, I sometimes
feel like there's things
that I want to share,
but I feel like, because
of the nature of my work,
I have to hide what I'm doing--
not hide, but there's
company confidentiality,
and I want to obscure
that, then share.
And that's just a tricky piece.
And have you had to
deal with that before?
Has anyone here had to deal
with that before, of wanting
to share things they've done
in R, but at the same time,
they're concerned about
their company's data--
not the company's data,
but just that process?
All right.
So let me start with
on the repeat analysis.
I think for me, it's not to
eliminate the repeats analysis.
I think that repeat
analysis is precisely
the valuable bits of the work.
If you're with me, like getting
that, especially when there's
some kind of domain expert, that
back and forth to get something
out there is really valuable.
And it's, actually,
that back and forth
that I want to enable and
protect that both parties end
up quite satisfied.
Not to-- I mean, there's
a difference between,
let's say, asking
someone to redo work
because the communication was
faulty in the first place.
That's a different problem.
That's just getting the
two working together
well, understanding
the definitions,
or being clear on the output.
But when things are
going very well,
that back and forth and repeat
I quite like to keep going.
Because then, for
every iteration,
there's more value
being extracted out
of the data we have.
So I go, yeah, cool,
now can we look at this?
Now can we look at that?
What about this?
What about that?
I really, yeah, so I'll
try and encourage that.
But it's how to
still let that happen
is by protecting the time of
the person doing that work,
that they don't feel like
they have to juggle and do
the switching.
Because then they
don't want to also
get into this back and forth,
and can we look at this,
can we look at that?
So it's more about--
I sort of see it as
is the stream of time
that you're trying to protect.
And as long as it's
needed, it's got
to be insulated until
that's closed off.
At some point, it
will come to an end.
So yeah.
So it's flipping on its
head a little bit there.
On sharing work, yeah.
So I can tell you what I do.
I just don't share the stuff
that even I really want to, I
just don't.
I haven't found a
very good way for me
to be able to show a
lot of what we're doing.
But then, I zoom out a
little bit into other things
that I find interesting.
For example, I want to talk
about some of the projects
we do.
But it's a bit difficult. I
mean, I think at some point,
I be may be able
to do it more when
I've got more time to do it.
But I'll zoom out a little bit.
And what else do I
think is interesting,
like project management?
How do you manage your team?
I'm trying to think
of some other things.
I was quite interested in
some of these certifications
that you see out there
that I've seen many,
many new data
analysts are getting.
And I wanted to--
so like the Google data
analytics one, for example.
I was super interested
in assessing
what do I think about the
content as a hiring manager?
Now, that's not
NDA stuff for us.
It's nothing.
So I went and did it.
And it's still interesting.
And then, that I wrote about.
So it still scratches
that itch of being
able to share information, not
always the exact information
I want.
What I have seen someone
else do is they took,
for something they
worked on with us,
they did a demo on their
own toy project to test it.
And that's how they learned
before they came and did it.
And then, that's
how they pitched us.
No, we'd really like to do this
type of thing on your project
or on this project
we're working on.
But they'd just done
their demo of it
publicly on a toy data set.
So they still also got that
kind of scratching that itch
while being able to
share it a little bit.
But, yeah.
But I'm keen on
if anyone else has
been able to come up with some
cool NDA protection backend
whatever.
What would you say?
I can't think of the word now.
I see, Marlene,
you had some ideas
of what you're working on.
Say what?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I
saw you said, you
had some ideas of
how you were sharing
this public-facing portfolio.
So I was curious if you
wanted to share maybe
how you were doing that?
Oh, sure.
So for those of you who don't
know, I work in agriculture.
And some of the projects we
work on here, for example,
are food safety-related,
where we're
showing lab tests of products.
So a piece of lettuce
that gets sent to a lab
and then it gets homogenized and
tested for foodborne pathogens,
like E coli.
And then, we'll show those on
a map positive or negative.
By the way, when you
see a positive on a map,
doesn't mean anything terrible.
It just means that something
lived there, an organism.
But anyway, my point is
that maps can very easily
be misconstrued.
So I did a mock-up for this.
It's right now
nationally blowing up
this food safety data-sharing
project that my trade
organization put together.
But we went from the
prototype that I built in R
to having a subcontractor
redoing it in basically a click
dashboard.
Which, by the way, I feel is
not as clean and as beautiful
as some of the leaflet packages.
That's just my personal opinion.
But it gets the job done.
But anyway, I really want to
take that prototype of the map
that I built and make
it public-facing.
But there is no way.
People will come
slamming on my door
if I have positives
and negatives on a map.
So my thought was,
instead, to do something
like here are where
commodities are located,
because that's not
necessarily sensitive.
And I would have to
take a public data set.
Those of you who are
asking about public data
sets, there are a ton
out there, by the way.
It's just a matter of finding
a good one for your use case.
You can literally just
Google Public data sets.
Academia has their
hands on tons of them.
So they're definitely out there.
But I've taken things like--
feel free to laugh at this--
I know that, because I
used to work with the Water
Board of California, that
they have testing for streams,
like certain fish or
bioassays that are done there.
And I've taken those
and just jig them,
move them a fraction of
a GPS point up or down,
and just been like,
here's my new point.
And we're going to fake that
here's where lettuce is grown
or radishes are grown.
So you might see a radish grown
in the middle of a stream.
But, hey, I just put a
giant caveat along the top
that this is meant for
demonstration purposes.
It's fake data, et cetera.
But I'm basically going
through that whole process
for everything that
I've ever built,
which is not a huge
portfolio, because I
feel like the most of
the things I've built
are pretty action-packed
in a single tool.
So there's a lot of hours
packed into a single tool.
But I hope that
makes sense on some
of the ways you can
de-identify some of your data.
I think it's more important
to show the visualizations
and to also have a page that
chronicles the process a bit.
So they understand all the work
that goes in rather than just,
here's your snapshot.
Because we do live
in an age where
people are a little
underwhelmed now,
thank you CGI and great movies,
by beautiful visualizations.
So you have to let them know,
there are a lot of blood,
sweat, and tears
that went into this.
So anyway, there's
my two-second spiel
on how to maybe de-identify
some of your work.
Thank you, Marlene.
Yeah, that's such
a great point too.
Because I was even just talking
about that internally at Posit
that if we show an example
that's using mtcars,
it's not going to look the
same to a finance company.
They want to-- even
if it's play data,
they want to see
something that actually is
relevant to their industry too.
Another question for you, Oscar.
We talk a lot about
this shift from being
an individual contributor
to moving into management.
And something I've
seen you write about
before is hiring to replace you
versus hiring for the skills
you don't have.
And just wanted to open up
the discussion about that too.
Yeah, so this was--
I'll give credit to, I think
his name's Michael Kaminski
from the locally
optimistic Slack group.
It's also highly
recommend for anyone
who's on this call
to join that as well.
But, yeah, so it was--
so when you're getting
into a management position,
at some point you need
to start hiring people
and a team around you.
And hiring is actually
very different
depending at different
points in your career.
I thought that it
had been the same,
because I had done
hiring before,
even when I wasn't a manager.
And it does actually come
this split that, I think,
takes some people by
surprise the first time
it starts happening, because it
certainly took me by surprise.
So before you're, let's
say, a manager manager,
if you are growing
in your career
and you do happen to
be hiring someone,
you are hiring someone
most likely to replace you,
like a more junior
version of yourself.
And you're going to train them.
And you are the
expert of some level,
and you're going
to bring them up
to your level or
something like that.
And so, and also you
feel, I suppose, in a way,
quite secure in
what it is you're
doing because you've already got
much more knowledge than them.
And you are bringing
them up to your level.
And so, you feel very confident
in answering the questions
and mentoring them
and all of that.
But it becomes very
different if you're
starting to hire for
skills you don't have.
So, for example, I don't
have a stats background.
I don't have a data
engineering background.
I don't have even
that much, actually,
of an analyst background.
I was a market analyst,
not a data analyst, per se.
And when you start hiring these
team members into your team,
these are for
skills I don't have.
It becomes much more difficult
for me to also assess
what are they good or not?
And also, very quickly,
it's kind of weird.
I first started, like I
think most people start,
I was trying to learn as much
data engineering and data
science as I could
to try and just
stay at least up with them.
But there's no way
that you can do that.
And, actually, it's then
the sort of click happens.
And you're like, OK, wait,
actually, my job is not
to be the experts of all
of the people in my team.
I am just the mostly, really,
a glorified facilitator
of their work.
And if I know more
than them, that's
probably actually a problem.
We can't have me be
with my 10% of time
on all of these
different vast fields
be still the expert
in everything.
That's not going to be great.
And that's quite a
different switch.
And when it's--
I think it takes
a bit of getting
used to to start
not understanding
bits of what it is.
Then the tables
turn a little bit.
I'm in some ways the
non-technical manager
of technical people, though
I'm kind of technical myself.
But they'll talk about
things, and I also
have to be like, whoa, whoa.
Then I start also clicking
a lot of what my directors
and execs feel like sometimes.
I'm like, yeah, you're getting
into way too much detail.
I can't do anything with
what you're telling me.
But then also it
gets much better
in trying to assess,
OK, what's the options?
My role mostly is
to try and not just
prioritize work but
try and help them
uncover where there's
work needs to be done,
or if there's a dilemma,
try and break down, well,
what if we go this direction?
How bad will it be
if this happens,
or how good will it
be if this happens?
Can we weigh risk like this?
So I can convey to them
as well where things just
aren't a priority.
Because no matter what they
do or stress about here,
it ain't going to matter later.
So that's quite a
different ballpark.
And, yeah, I think it probably
happens the first time you hire
someone that's not a
replacement for you,
it's an addition to your team.
So, yeah.
It can catch you by surprise.
Any other tips for
us if we're navigating
that first hire,
where you don't have
the same skill set as them?
How you communicate with
them, or in your one-on-ones
with them?
I'm very clear that,
up front, that I am not
the skilled person
that they will
be able to come to for
x, y, z technical thing.
I just don't have that.
And they can't
expect that of me.
But I am quite clear
about what I can provide
and what my role is, and
that I am interested, still,
in their technical
development and in--
but they need to guide
me about what they think,
where they think they should go.
They're going to tell me
some gobbledygook new thing
like, OK, da, da, da
and then I'm like,
OK, I just need to assess.
This is what I'll need to assess
if this is going to be good
or not.
So I suppose being much more--
I'm very clear about
my thought processes
and my decision-making.
So I do that very vocally.
If I'm weighing up things,
I'm talking out loud.
OK, if we do this, then it's--
so that it's not this
black box for them
about they gave me
some information
and then I just gave
the decision back.
I think that's also been
quite helpful in getting
our communication
to work quite well.
Yeah, especially when
you have with people
with different backgrounds.
And I feel like career
development is such a big part
of being a manager.
But I don't know if it's
necessarily something
that managers are always taught.
And I'm wondering
how do you learn
about growing your
team's career and having
those conversations with them?
Yeah, I think in
one way, now, for many
this might sound blasphemous.
But in one way, I try
and take the company out
of this equation totally,
not just our immediate needs.
And I think, what's going to be
really great for this person's
career in general?
If I bumped into you 5 years
or 10 years down the line,
in a selfish way, it
would be fantastic
if your career was
just going swimmingly.
It's good to have context if
careers are just really flying.
And then I work
backwards from that
and then say, OK, I think
would this be better for you?
Would that be better for you?
Or don't worry too much.
If you could do anything,
what would you do?
And then, of course, you need
to try and whittle down and say,
could we apply some of that
now in what we're doing?
Or do you see an opportunity?
Is it something that
really interests you?
That really helps a lot.
But, actually, I found
another way as well
is to let people go with
their curiosity as well.
And I think that's one thing
that at least I can appreciate
coming from some kind
of technical background
is, actually, most of
my career development
has been from just the bits
that I was curious about that I
couldn't explain to
someone exactly what was
the ROI on this
thing going to be.
I don't know, it's
just you get a sense
that some things may pay off.
Even if it doesn't, you're
going to learn quite a lot.
So I try and give a
lot of room for if you
want to go try that, just
go do it type of thing.
And I trust that some way you'll
benefit and we'll benefit,
whether it's successful or not.
I try and make a lot
of room for that.
Thank you.
OSCAR BARUFFA: Yeah.
I want to make sure
I go over to some
of these anonymous
questions too.
And somebody had asked,
I have acquired skills
in project management
and program evaluation.
Could you elaborate more on
the application of project
management to data analytics?
Well, yeah.
As data is becoming used in
organizations a lot more,
and if you come from the
digitally-native organization,
you might not realize this.
But coming from any kind
of traditional organization
that's everyone, let's
say, not a digital producer
of some kind, data is becoming
more and more infused daily
into work.
Sometimes not always at the
pace we like, but it is.
And data as products are
becoming more ubiquitous.
So someone wants
to develop a tool
that assesses something,
or a shiny dashboard,
or any other dashboard,
or data starts
moving back and
forth between places,
and these things
need to be managed,
whether in whole
or just in chunks.
And I think that's where
the project management
application from
a data perspective
comes and will keep
growing as companies
start adopting that kind of
data as a product mindset.
Like, oh, this is not
just this inert data.
It's not just, yeah,
this inert pile of stuff
that we occasionally will
pick from when we need it.
It becomes this more living
integral part of work
that someone needs
to maintain, someone
needs to have a vision for.
And then, naturally,
projects around
that grow because you
want to upgrade things,
you want to add
new capabilities.
So that's where
I see it hitting.
And that's partly also
why this data project
management for data
analyst book is useful,
because a lot of data people
find themselves suddenly
managing a project,
like, oh, I've
got to get the comms people
involved for the, I don't know,
the fonts on the
frontend of my thing
that I'm about to publish.
Or I need to talk to
just more and more people
as data starts touching more
bits of the organization.
You've got to align a lot of
people around some deliverable.
Definitely.
Thank you.
I love all these
packages and resources
that are being shared in
the chat right now too.
It looks like there's a lot
of great resources on making
dummy data sets
and synthetic data.
Another anonymous
question-- actually,
first, let's jump to
your question, Sal.
I see you asked a
question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
And I can ask it if you want
to jump in with more context.
But the question was,
at a certain level,
I feel that managers are
told, let your employees be
autonomous, but simultaneously
managers and chain of command
have very specific expectations.
Do you have experience
in balancing autonomy
and directing towards
a desired result?
Yeah, I don't think those
things are mutually exclusive.
I mean, I suppose maybe,
just personally, I've
been quite lucky.
I've always had a
lot of autonomy.
But I think autonomy--
now, I'm not talking about,
let's say, toxic workplaces
where people are
micromanaging and there's
power plays and all that.
Let's just say, there's
at least some level
of maybe autonomy
being earned, perhaps,
let's say in those
situations where you really
could be given a lot of
autonomy to achieve your goals,
but it's still not happening.
It's earned in the
sense that under--
it's going to sound so cliche--
but really understanding
what the business is
trying to achieve really helps.
Because then most people--
in my experience-- most people
don't want to micromanage.
They want to just let
people run with things right
and deliver results.
And I think that
kind of autonomy
not just comes from
understanding the business,
but I found a lot of it's
about being very empathetic,
especially about
those higher up who
are accountable for the
outputs of whatever it is.
So and what that
means-- what I mean
by it is, I often put myself
in the shoes of those who
are saying they want to turn to
me, or they need these results,
or whatever.
And I really think,
OK, what are they--
if I was them, what am
I trying to deal with?
I've also got, I didn't sleep
the night before, my kids were
up, and I've got all these
emails that are in here,
and da, da, da, da, da, da.
And I'm about to send
an email that says,
I can't do this without
these resources.
I'm going to be like,
that's not going to land.
And that's it's
maybe one small way
in doing it is when you practice
that kind of empathetic aspect,
then it's helped me
a lot phrase things.
Well, what's the most helpful
I can still be in order
to move things along, even
if it, something went wrong,
or I-- and then, that's
really helped me a lot.
Because then I can
say, well, I've
also done the work
of really trying
to understand what it is
we're trying to achieve
and what the trade-offs
are at the higher up we go.
And then I'll try and
frame things in the same--
the alternatives
that are available.
And then, I also show that
I've thought about if we do x,
we're not going to reach this.
But it will maybe do y.
But if we do this,
it's going to do that.
And I recommend also, always,
say what you recommend.
The higher up you go, there's
decision-fatigue like crazy.
It really helps to
say, I've thought
about all these trade-offs,
and this is what I recommend.
So I mean, I can't say if this
will definitely always help.
But it always feels
like the times
that I haven't really put in the
effort to do that kind of work,
then things don't often go
as smoothly or as I'd like.
Then I get the answers
that I don't always--
I would prefer maybe not to get,
or the response lands badly.
Yeah.
I wanted to put a plug out
here for your website as well.
Because I came across
an article that you
wrote that I found very
interesting on dealing
with difficult stakeholders.
Oh, yeah.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
And I would love
to give some time to that topic.
And for people who might be
on the call who are hearing,
we're too busy to go
forward with this project,
or this is way down
on our priority
list, what are some things
they can do to get past that?
Yeah.
So that post is like a
collection of every, let's say,
approach that I could
think of that I've
employed to make working
with stakeholders
easier in some way.
And they'll work in
different contexts.
But I think that for
me, the most effective
has always been canvassing.
I think, I don't
know, but I think
I put eight there or nine, I
can't remember, but canvassing.
And most of you probably
already do this,
or you're not sure it's
called canvassing or whatever.
But when you're getting the
buy-in, especially when there's
a group, or any
kind of committee,
or any joint decision,
getting their buy-in
before the actual
public-facing meeting
is really the only way to
get really good progress.
And what's difficult about it
is it's extremely time-consuming
because, of course, the
bigger the committee is,
the bigger you've got to go.
And a key to that is
that trying to understand
people's incentives, like
politically in the organization
or whatever, they sense us
for accepting things or not.
And so, when you're
trying to set up
these one-on-one
meetings, and that those
you want to keep quite small.
Because the best thing
I've found is people
need to be able to
back out of things.
If you put people in a
corner and you want their--
that's what doing publicly in
the group is not a good idea.
If you're trying
to get people's--
you want to give
them wiggle room.
And doing the
one-on-ones beforehand,
and not following
those up in writing.
I mean, unless you're
already in some kind
of combative situation
and you need to do it,
you need to do it.
But this is, ideally,
all the legwork
you do way ahead of
time, that you understand
where they're coming from,
what they can agree to,
what they can't agree to.
And it's great if
you can go around
and you understand what's
their main concerns
or what is it they're
looking for from this project
or from whatever.
And you build that
in beforehand,
that ideally you've
got the agreements.
Then by the time it comes
to the group agreement,
everyone's already agreed.
And you will have
to sometimes live
with this uncertainty of
some people not agreeing,
but they will at least
not object to the work
or object to what
it is you're doing.
And sometimes I
find that was also
for me, in the first few times
I had to do this kind of thing,
I wanted the certainty,
so of everyone
giving me the yes before I
go and spend all this time.
But the reality is, you
won't get it from everyone.
But for me, no
objection is as good.
And usually then after the
thing's got a bit of momentum,
the objections don't--
they are too late then later.
But a lot of people, they
want the ability to back out.
And sometimes I
think if that's what
they need to be able to
let this thing go forward,
then you just got to
be pragmatic about it,
and then just say, great, that's
as good as it's going to get.
Thank you.
I wanted to, as we come to
the top of the hour here,
I just want to make sure
if there are questions
that I didn't ask
yet, that people have
an opportunity here to
raise your hand or repost
something in the Zoom chat.
One that was over on
Slido was going back
to the Big Book of R.
And somebody had asked--
I'm finding the question here.
But, essentially, how do you
keep up with all of the links
and make sure that
they're not dead?
Because so many of
those books or websites
are changed over time.
Yeah, that's actually--
I think the magic of version
control and book [INAUDIBLE]
actually means that links
don't break that often.
For a start, people republish
back to the same points.
So, yeah, it's actually not
been too difficult to keep
that kind of thing going.
Occasionally,
what's also quite--
I suppose because I'm
also fairly reachable--
if someone finds a dead link,
they just tag me and say, hey,
this link is dead.
So I'm not the one actually
doing the maintenance on that
per se.
And many people are very kind.
They'll also say,
this isn't working.
This is the new link.
So my work is super easy.
So I'd say that's where people
are being really helpful helps.
And let's say, keeping up
just in more general of adding
books, so that is a
bit more of a challenge
because there's always
quite a lot being added.
But I have very
recently also drafted
in some help from Niels Olsen.
You'll see in one of my updates.
He's is a fellow
data nerd in Germany.
He very kindly
volunteered to help.
So the last couple of
batches he's been doing.
It takes, actually, quite a lot
of time to look at the entries.
Because I want to make
sure that it is an R book.
It has the kind of relevance.
Where does it go?
What should the introduction be?
That takes a lot of
time to do all of that.
So I've drafted in a
bit of help because it
was getting a bit much.
Yeah.
Great.
Another question I realized
I had missed from earlier.
Somebody asked, do you
have recommendations
for useful resources
for beginners in R,
even beyond books?
They said, I'm overwhelmed
with the available resources
and unsure where to start.
Yeah.
I point to where probably
most people would
is R for DS, book
by Hadley and always
forget the second author.
That's how it goes.
And then there's also a video--
if you want a video course.
So, actually, on
the Big Book of R,
there's a Big Book of R
slash Start Here I think,
which is, indeed,
if you are very new,
they are the two resources.
One is the book, and one's
a series of free videos
from all R the rest of us
that you can check it out.
But I mean, I'd say, I'm not a
fantastic R programmer at all.
I'm just not that fantastic.
But what's great
is you don't even
need to be very fantastic to
get a lot of use and power
out of it, and I'm 20
times more productive.
So I think if you're
a beginner from R,
I mean, I did half
of the R for DS book.
And it's been insanely useful
just the first 10 or 15
chapters or so.
I've done basically everything
I do now is just from that.
So you don't need to learn
everything, just learn
a couple of things
and get going.
I'm trying to copy and paste
the Big Book of R Start Here.
There it goes.
For some reason, Zoom wasn't
letting me paste for a second.
And, Andy, yeah, thanks
for the recommendation
on the Posit cloud primers.
They're a great resource too
if you wanted to share that.
We had a team go through--
I was at Academy
this last winter.
And we had two
folks that had never
programmed in R before when
they signed up for Academy.
So those cloud primers were
super helpful for folks
to come up to speed.
All right.
Cool.
OK.
Great.
Trevor, I see you just
put a question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
Hi, everyone.
I'm in sunny Jamaica,
just to let you know.
I do work for a multinational
firm in Jamaica, IGT.
If you look up us, you can
look on the Stock Exchange
and you'll find us.
All right, so I've been
watching the conversations
around the very new
shiny toy, ChatGPT,
and even barred from Google.
I've been watching
the conversations
about what we think.
And it's still evolving--
Yeah.
--about what this
will mean for us.
Will we write in code or not?
So I just wanted to
get your thoughts
on how do you see those
applications affecting what
we do positively or negatively?
Yeah, thanks.
Thanks.
So, yeah, we'll see what the
test of time will tell us.
I think it'll be a useful tool.
But we will soon find out
what its limitations are.
I'm a bit--
I'm mostly worried
that it's not going
to be as cool as we
think, that it's not
going to be as useful and
revolutionary, mostly.
I'm not worried that
it's going to be so going
to take over everything
and that, I suppose,
because I saw AR and VR was
going to change everything.
And then it sort of fizzled out.
And then blockchain was
going to change everything.
And that kind of--
there's a couple
of useful little things for it.
And then I saw NFTs were
going to change everything.
And then, that's kind of died,
in my opinion, thank goodness.
So and then crypto was
going to change everything.
And then-- I mean, the
difference is ChatGPT--
I've used it a few times.
And I found it useful, at
least the version I have.
We've got a-- well, some are
wishlists in a way to use it
for some elements of our work.
Especially we've got a lot
of contextual information.
So I like the idea of
being able to retrain it
on our own content
and then use it
in some very specific
applications of trying
to summarize some stuff.
And I think, yeah, I think,
if it does very, very well,
it will be useful.
History shows it's
going to fizzle out
to a couple of other
use cases, or I really
hope it does fantastically well.
Because I think what my
feeling is, it's going to--
if it does
fantastically well, it's
going to ease a lot of the
low-level work that is not
of enough value to hire someone
for, or to farm out to someone.
We just live with the mess
of not doing the summary,
or not drafting this
thing, or whatever.
We just kind of deal with it
because it's not enough value.
And then it will be fantastic.
And I think, on balance,
it will be very useful
if it's very good.
So we'll see.
But we'll see what happens.
OK, thank you.
OSCAR BARUFFA: I'm hopeful
that it's going to be good.
Yeah.
And Trevor, it looks
like a lot of people
want to come work
with you in Jamaica.
[LAUGHTER]
They want to come
to Jamaica at least.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Yes.
At least come to Jamaica.
Yes.
You're invited.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Well,
thank you so much,
Oscar, for joining and
sharing your insights with us.
This has been so fun.
OSCAR BARUFFA: Yeah.
If people want to
stay in touch with you,
is the best way through
LinkedIn, or Twitter,
or Mastodon?
Yeah, I'd say
probably LinkedIn
is the one I would check
the most these days.
I'm just trying to
find my LinkedIn.
Yeah, if I'm not
checking messages.
And, thanks, yeah, please,
everyone, do connect with me.
I've seen some connection
requests come through.
I'll also post it here.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Awesome.
And, yeah, I'd say there.
And then, also, my
newsletter as well.
I mean, if you're
interested in that,
I always read any
email replies to that.
But probably LinkedIn's
the best these days.
But thanks.
And this hour went by so fast.
It goes by very
quickly, right?
I wanted to put one more
plug at the end for the Big
Book of R and the form that
you mentioned to get support.
OSCAR BARUFFA: Thanks so much.
And I'm trying to
grab that real quickly.
Here it is.
So I just put that
form there if anybody
is interested in
helping out there too.
But thank you so much, Oscar.
That was great.
Yeah.
Thanks for the invite.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks.
Have a great rest
of the day, everybody.